on parlait de l'impact épouvantable de
lakovic 19 hier sur l'hébergement et le
tourisme avec christiane germain
ce soir le secteur manufacturier et le
commerce transfrontalier avec les états
unis
marc dutil et pdg du groupe canam il est
avec nous ce soir bonsoir monsieur dutil
bon sang c'est fini dites-nous là vous
êtes chez vous à saint-georges si je me
trompe pas comment ça se passe chez vous
chez canam comment ça affecte aussi vos
activités vos employés mais je vous
dirais que le cio il ya plusieurs
centaines de personnes qui sont mises à
pied de quelques centaines de personnes
qui sont en temps partagé
mais malgré tout faut que je choisisse
ou non à mon nom et au nom d'entreprises
d'être reconnaissant on est
reconnaissant parce qu'on retourne et en
santé dans l'organisation
comme plusieurs compagnies du québec
hockey ou l'amérique du nord une
accélération d'adaptation technologique
en fonctionnement le plus de 900
personnes en télétravail chez canam qui
soudainement apprennent comment ça
marche
pis aussi curieux que ce soit je pense
qu'il ya un rapprochement affligeant
yoyo il ya tellement de conversations
qui ont lieu qui aurait pas lieu il ya
quelque chose qui se passe maintenant
puis on a maintenant l'occasion pour
vous occuper du maintenant il faut
s'occuper du demain puis de demain est
très stimulant onu des enjeux au niveau
du transport aux états unis mais on peut
livrer des pros des matières premières
on peut servir des clients américains
quand c'est essentiel qu en général je
voudrais que ça va relativement bien
vous avez même implanté un protocole
quand même de sécurité dans vos usines
très rapidement expliquez nous ce que
vous avez fait ce protocole je vous
expliquer le pourquoi on est en échange
sur nos 360 collègues en roumanie puis
les roumains ont vu venir la vague bien
avant nous il nous disait faut envoyer
le monde à la maison et on se disait
mais de quoi qui parle et quand qu'on a
finalement compris je voudrais que canam
au québec on avait une dizaine
jour d'avant sur qu'est ce qu'on va
faire ce quelqu'un est un effectif qu
est-ce qu on fasse quelqu'un reste avec
quelqu'un qui est infecté s'écouler
protocole de désinfection commun qu'on
sépare les quarts de travail commun
qu'on sépare les usines commun quand on
leur rapidement commencer à réfléchir
aso pourrait pour éviter la réflexion et
introduire l'automatisme et caen qui
arrive quelque chose c'est ce qu'on fait
on ne fait rapidement et je vous disais
je suis contente de ce que l'équipe
prophète ne plus partager avec d'autres
entreprises ou si la frontière est
fermée pour les gens mais elle est
ouverte bien sûr pour le transport des
biens des marchandises vous êtes le type
d'entreprise qui traversent souvent
cette frontière là comment ça se passe
mais on reçoit de la matière première
qui fait qu'on reçoit sa première dont
notre besoin que les gens peuvent se
demander ce que c'était sensibles ou
peaux
mais ce qui est essentiel c'est de ne
pas engorger les moyens de transport ça
fait quand on reçoit des choses qui
paraissent à la frontière faut pardonner
le chat avec mon fils joseph lucky qui
marmonne un problème qui en livre des
projets aux attouchements
on livre des hôpitaux en livres d
aéroport on livre des centres de
distribution et les services frontaliers
aujourd'hui son extraordinaire ils font
la distinction entre madame colle
redonner à son chalet et se produire il
est nécessaire pour continuer à
construire et aucun enjeu jusque là
est-ce que vous avez une entreprise
comme vous canam besoin du soutien de
l'aide gouvernementale en ce moment ce
qu'on a besoin
si vous me disiez combien de temps ça va
durer je vais vous répondre
si ça dure deux semaines mais on passera
au travers si ça dure deux ans va
vraiment de la misère ça fait travailler
sur quel scénario alors vous jean
l'orangé rouge auquel avec moi je suis
dans leur âme je suis pas dans le rouge
pendant john
et à cause que tu le sais pas quand
quelqu'un t'offre un support faut que tu
l'accès à ce qu'il y aura pas de
rétroaction toliara pas de j'aurai du
fait qu'encore quand qu'un partenaire
financier nous offre de reporter
certains paiements ont dit oui encore
fournisseurs nous dit j'accepte détendre
mais mettant le crédit ont dit oui je
crois qu'un gouvernement dit voici des
ressources qui vont vous aider
on dit oui mais moi ma job monsieur
fillion la sexta reprise ne soit encore
là dans 15 ans à créer de la richesse à
créer des emplois à redonner à la
communauté
et aujourd'hui si je peux poser si nous
pouvons poser des gestes qui la rendent
plus pérenne mais on n'a pas le choix il
faut les poser les justes c'est quoi vos
conseils ou votre conseil principal aux
entrepreneurs qui nous écoutent ce soir
j'en ai plusieurs ans et à long terme
et puis c'est vraiment difficile parce
qu'on y vend la l'immédiat ok la maison
et poignant feu faut sauver tout le
monde l'urgence on aura pas de débat
dans l'urgence mais une fois l'urgence
est derrière nous il faut penser à long
terme
puis le parallèle jouffre en 80 ans qui
est une crise économique plus difficile
que celle qu'on vit maintenant à singer
on ne fait beaucoup de coups peut on a
fait des mises à pied en forme et
lumière dans l'usiné qui les derniers
sous qui nous restait on a décidé de
bâtir une usine puis hachez les
équipements modernes et parle à 25 ans
de créer de l'emploi avec ses
investissements londres est des stades à
travers toute l'amérique
parce que dans le creux de la misère on
le dit
demeyer 120 kw et nous ressources on les
a mis dans demain je vous hais et puis
pour les entrepreneurs
tout le monde est pareil la santé des
employés fauchère m'est rien faut que
mais notre obligation c'est préserver
l'entreprise à long terme
en terminant je vois derrière vous qu'il
ya quelque chose d'écrit dans l'escalier
je m'excuse mais je veux vraiment faire
voir qu'est ce qui est écrit si je peux
me permettre à gg privilège avons
beaucoup voyagé et
ma fille a amené justin a décidé
d'écrire dans les marches les
destinations et dans le milieu a dit
latéraux ça cette inscription à l autre
trois ans mais il me semble très près
par l'histoire et qu à sa fête merci t
on on en profite de tout le monde est en
santé mes parents mes enfants fait que
vous croisez les doigts parce que c'est
pas c'est pas vrai que tout va mal il ya
des choses qui vont bien
marc dutil c'est toujours un grand
plaisir de vous écouter merci beaucoup
merci monsieur fignon